foreign
s of years before the events of Skyward
Sword God is highly has sent a piece of
Hyrule surface up into the heavens on it
was the sod after Triforce along with
the remaining human survivors of a Great
War kept safe Out Of Reach from the
genocidal Wrath of demise and his
fearsome demon tribe as a final measure
hylia created a powerful barrier that
would separate Heaven and Earth before
turning her attention back to fighting
demise and ultimately sealing him away
for the time being over the next
Millennia the residents of the sky built
a new civilization with its own unique
culture fashion customs and beliefs and
the island itself came to be known as
skyloft so what we have here is a group
of people who lived out their entire
lives completely isolated for thousands
of years generation after generation
everyone they knew and would ever know
was born in the sky and in the sky they
will breathe their last nevertheless
skyloft is a sprawling town the people
are content and as expected from an
isolated civilization like this there's
a strong sense of community all seems
well in skyloft and for the most part it
is especially compared to some of the
other cities towns and Villages from
past games but there's a few haunting
details about skyloft that inhibits a
village of the Year award events which
despite skyward Swords relatively tame
approach to horror are still pretty
unsettling when you dig further into the
implications themes and possible
real-life Inspirations for it in today's
video we'll cover two subjects for the
price of one and as a bonus we'll even
discuss the possibility of a connection
between these two seemingly disconnected
events these speculations don't have to
be true by any means and as per usual
are probably me overthinking it but hey
if it makes for a more spooky story all
the better with that said happy
Halloween and let's dive into the
Curious Case of skyloft
foreign
[Music]
skyloft will study at the Knight Academy
at some point in their lives where they
will learn to master their loftwing and
are taught the ways of the sword until
they graduate as Knights individuals who
are tasked with keeping order and
protecting the island and its people
until the next Generation comes of age
as of the time of Skyward Sword there's
a total of seven students who live and
train at the Academy Lincoln Zelda
included other permanent residents
include two instructors Orwell and Olin
and lastly the school's Headmaster
gepora who also happens to be Zelda's
father additionally there's two
individuals who are often present at the
Academy but don't actually live there
the graduate student pippet who acts as
a sort of role model for the younger
students and henya the school's cook
however there's one more occupant at the
Academy and I'm not talking about the
cat an entity unseen by most yet whose
voice can be heard echoing through the
hallways after Nightfall
[Music]
the chilling haunting sounds of someone
in pain or some sort of emotional
distress the first person to take notice
of the Eerie voice is henya who swears
that during the late hours she keeps
hearing a voice coming from the restroom
right next to the kitchen on the first
floor but instead of being creeped out
by it her attitude is one of annoyance
as opposed to fear the other staff never
mentioned the voice from the restroom
probably because their rooms are on the
second floor as for the students only
link himself and Colin seem to be aware
of it and in the case of Colin it's
because link tells him about it he then
goes on to refer to this mysterious
individual as the weirdo in the restroom
it seems both henya and Colin assume
that it's just a normal person who
locked themselves into the restroom for
some reason but as most of you know this
individual is anything but normal when
link finally gains access to the
restroom at night the source of the
creepy voices revealed to be that of a
ghostly hand reaching out from the
bathroom stall one who for unknown
reasons is calling out for paper to
those who've played Oracle of Aegis or
Majora's Mask this will no doubt be
familiar as it's not the first time that
we find a mysterious hand reaching out
from a bathroom requesting paper it's
become sort of a weird recurring theme
in Zelda however one thing that sets The
Entity from Skyward Sword apart from the
other two is that thanks to Phi we have
some substantial information about it we
know that it's an actual ghost that it's
a young woman and that it's a being who
Harbors unfulfilled desires preventing
it from moving on to the afterlife we
even have a name that being Feeney now
the origin of the name Feeney is
actually quite interesting because this
was never established in the original
Skyward Sword on the Wii in part because
no NPC ever mentions her by name and the
dialog box did not display the name of
whoever it is you were talking to
something that was changed in Skyward
Sword HD however the name Feeney was
already hinted at long before the HD
remaster of the game on switch its first
appearance comes from an official
strategy guide from 2011 also known as
the Skyward Sword Prima official game
guide where it is mentioned in the
chapter about side quests the name would
later show up again in the Zelda
encyclopedia seven years later and
finally Feeney was confirmed to be her
official name in Skyward Sword HD oh and
in case you're wondering her Japanese
name is similar that being fenny instead
of Feeney most of you who played Skyward
Sword will no doubt be familiar with
Feeney as she's part of a pretty famous
side quest or at least she can be
depending on the choice you make it's
one of only a few side quests in the
series that have two different outcomes
one of Link's classmates Colin will ask
him to deliver a love letter to karane
one of the girls from the academy he has
a crush on if you do it'll result in
calling getting rejected by karane in
favor of the older graduate student
pippet and in this outcome Feeney will
tell link to forget about the paper says
her goodbyes after which The Haunting at
the Academy seems to stop however you
can also give Collins letter to Feeney
instead in which case she gives link her
thanks and here too ceases to haunt the
bathroom it's not until later that you
realize that handing Colin's letter to
Feeney has led her to develop feelings
for him and in what is perhaps one of
the most cruel and disturbing Fates ever
seen in the Zelda game she has now
latched herself onto him like some sort
of super natural stalker causing poor
Colin to have nightmares maybe for the
rest of his life
how that is dark so with all that said
who is or should I say was Feeney why
and how did she pass away at such a
young age and what caused her to linger
and haunt a school bathroom it goes
without saying that we'll probably never
know for sure as none of these questions
are ever answered in the game nor in the
books however this is a ghost story and
just like ghost hunters in real life we
can just make stuff up for views so the
main consensus about Feeney's name is
that it's based on the word Phoenix a
fictional bird from Greek and Chinese
mythology which does make sense in the
context of the English version of
Skyward Sword with the exception of Link
himself Zelda and batro all the NPCs in
town have names derived from Birds be it
the name of a bird or the sound they
make pigeons hens geese owls seagulls
and so on as such I believe that Feeney
was most definitely a former resident of
skyloft and not from the surface or some
other place the fact that Finney was
young and that she haunts the school in
particular points to her being a former
student at the academy one who
tragically lost her life at a young age
for reasons unknown despite the cruel
fate she bestows upon Collins she
doesn't seem to be an evil or eventual
Spirit but more so sad or lonely she
herself clarifies that she's not angry
she calls link a kind soul after giving
her the letter and her feelings for
Colin seem to be genuine and the
nightmare is more of an unfortunate side
effect of her presence as opposed to a
malicious act so what could have
happened to her was it murder
self-inflicted or maybe just a tragic
accident and what's up with a request
for paper in order to get a general idea
let's take a quick look at a few real
life Inspirations for Feeney's Story one
which has been brought up a lot as an
inspiration for Feeney is hanako the
angry Spirit of a girl who is set to
haunt school bathrooms she's kind of
like the Japanese equivalent of Bloody
Mary in the sense that she needs to be
summoned often as part of a dare by
Young students the summoning involves
going to the female bathroom usually on
the third floor knocking three times on
the third stall and then asking if
Hanukkah is present there's many
variations on hanukkah's Origin her
death and the unfortunate fate that
befalls her victims but I think you can
see why this story in particular is so
often referred to as the most likely
inspiration for the events in Skyward
Sword according to Miyamoto the
character of Feeney was indeed based on
Japanese ghost stories and urban legends
like this but not necessarily on one
specific Story and there's actually
quite a few Japanese tales and myths
besides Hanukkah about a ghost or demon
hunting a bathroom there is akamanto for
example a masked Spirit who appears in
public toilets or school bathrooms once
again the stories vary but one aspect
that stands out is that the akamanta
will ask the bathroom's occupant if they
want red or blue paper and the only way
to survive the encounter is to
completely ignore him and run away as
both choices lead to death the last one
I want to mention is the ghost story of
okiku a maid who worked in a samurai
mansion and drowned in a well either by
her own doing or because she was killed
by her master depending on the version
of the story after her death okiku's
Spirit comes out every night into the
mansion and breaks out into a terrible
howling and sobbing causing her former
Mass to go insane there's no specific
mention of a bathroom but the nightly
howling and sobbing as described in the
story does somewhat resemble that which
we hear in the academy whichever story
Feeney is ultimately derived from it's
all based on the same Japanese concept
the idea that a person's Spirit or
raycon will leave the body upon death it
then goes into purgatory where it awaits
a proper funeral and post-funeral rights
to be performed so that it may join its
ancestors however if the individual died
suddenly or violently the funeral rights
are not completed or if they are
influenced by powerful emotions such as
desire for Revenge love jealousy hatred
or sorrow at the moment of death the
raycon is believed to transform into a
Yuri a spirit who continues to exist on
Earth until it can be laid to rest
either by performing The Missing rituals
or resolving the emotional conflict that
ties it to the physical plane according
to Phi this is exactly the case with
Feeney as well an unfulfilled desire
that keeps her from moving on to the
afterlife some types of Yuri like
dionrio and gorio are considered
vengeful and dangerous but most are
harmless so I mischievous at best
there's even a specific class of Yuri
who are seductive and desire a
relationship with a living human
although Finney does indeed fall in love
with Colin I don't think this was the
initial cause and motivation behind the
haunting if anything it extends The
Haunting even further the fact that she
doesn't move on indicates that whatever
kept her on the physical plane was not
resolved in any way as mentioned before
the most likely option is that Feeney
used to be a student at the Academy back
when she was alive not only because of
her name but oftentimes Yuri will haunt
a location or individual they are
familiar with or have an attachment to
in this case the school that and the
fact that all young people in skyloft
study at the Academy at some point in
their lives even those who are not
particularly Brave I investigated every
house in skyloft to see if I could find
anything that could link Feeney to one
of the people or families living here in
the current day maybe a picture of a
girl who doesn't appear in game or even
an extra unused bed anything really but
alas as far as I'm aware no such
evidence seems to exist the only mildly
the interesting thing I did find is that
there are two unused character concepts
for Skyward Sword who are both young and
female and neither have a definitive
name however since they were never
actually implemented into the game it's
impossible to know if one of them
correlates to Feeney and realistically
speaking they probably don't there's
also no mention of a student who died
while studying at the Academy not by the
school staff or anyone in town for that
matter henya who first encounters The
Haunting is said to have been taking
care of the students at the school for
the past 25 years and she doesn't
recognize the voice in the bathroom nor
does she bring up any tragic Tales of
missing students or anything of sorts as
such I believe that she probably lived
and died and skyloft a long time ago
perhaps in the early days of the
institution or even before it was
established the fact that no one
mentions or even remembers a young woman
whose life was cut short definitely
points in that direction as for the way
she died my best guess would be an
unfortunate accident it's made obvious
by the knights and the academy staff
that flying a loft Wing as awesome as it
may be is not without risk and there's
quite a few rules and restrictions in
place to prevent unnecessary harm or
casualties like no flying after dark
unless you receive special training no
interfering with other Riders doing a
race there are Knights who Patrol the
skies in case someone falls off the
island and Advanced Techniques and
Maneuvers like the spiral charge are
only allowed to be performed by senior
students who have mastered high-level
flight skills however if there's
anything we know about human behavior it
is that rules and security measures are
often put into place after something
goes wrong first so perhaps in the early
days of the academy one of the students
met a tragic end due to an oversight
while flying their Loft Wing resulting
in their death another option I've
considered is that since the academy has
allegedly existed for only 25 years it's
also possible that Finney died much
longer ago and that her house once stood
where the school is now and so the
haunting is actually not related to the
academy at all anyway that wraps up the
story of Feeney for now so let's switch
gears to the second part of the darker
side of skyloft the demon battle and his
influence on the town
from a lower standpoint batro is one of
the most intriguing characters in the
entire Zelda series not because of who
he is but more so what he is a demon
who's been living and hiding at the
bottom of skyloft though interestingly
enough a friendly one now I'm not going
to get into the finer details about
demonic entities in Zelda lore because
that's a whole other topic on its own
but in short they are usually portrayed
as evil and associated with the
so-called tribe of demons who oppose the
gods Petro may just be the first and
only time we've encountered one that has
no ill intentions not only that but it's
also the first time that a demon is
capable of transforming into a human
there's a lot of mystery surrounding his
origin and how he ended up in skyloft in
the first place after all the whole
reason the island was sent into the Sky
by hylia was to keep the surviving
humans from being slaughtered by demons
it's possible that battle was originally
one of demise's followers and
essentially became a stowaway when
skyloft was lifted up into the heavens
this would mean that he's been living
here hidden away from sight for
thousands of years and his friendly
nature could simply be the result of him
being cut off from his tribe for so long
that he gave up on his evil Ambitions
and desired to become human I mean he
doesn't really have much of a choice
here this is definitely possible and
probably also the main consensus but
there's also an alternative while batro
is most certainly a demon we know that
not all of them are born this way for
example vati used to be a Minish and
then transformed into a demon later in
his life and even Ganondorf was once
nothing more than a thief a mortal
albeit a powerful one who became a demon
when he obtained a piece of the Triforce
so anyone could feasibly transform into
one given the right circumstances and
this concept Falls in line with the
Japanese shirio someone who slowly
transforms into a demon because of
repressed feelings of jealousy hatred
grief or sadness this being can be a
spirit but it can also happen to someone
who's alive as such it's possible that
batro's original form is that of a human
one who transformed at a later stage of
his life it would explain how he knows
it's possible to turn back into human
again in the first place his fashion
also matches that of the residence of
skyline left though this could also be a
failed attempt at a disguise so he can
mingle with the people in town it's
clear that batro is lonely and well who
can blame him he's been living in hiding
for who knows how long and any attempt
he's made to connect with the people of
skyloft resulted in fear and panic it's
not until one of the kids from town goes
missing who's later found hanging around
his house that he finally meets someone
who isn't immediately terrified of him
despite his good intentions and friendly
demeanor the very nature of him as a
demon has an unfortunate side effect on
the town above though one which he
doesn't seem to have any control over
it's revealed that the mere presence of
batro is Aura so to speak is directly
responsible for some of the crazy stuff
happening in skyloft after Nightfall not
just the various monsters that show up
but also the Sinister shift in the
behavior of one of the animals in town
that roamed the streets at night the
adorable cat-like pets who keep the
skyloftine's company seem totally normal
but after Sunset they are suddenly
overtaken by some sort of Rage making
them hostile and honestly kind of scary
to the people of skyloft this
transformation is a complete mystery and
seem to think that it's just part of
their nature little do they know that
the source lies right below their feet
after finishing batro's side quests and
transforming him into a human the
remlett ceased to become enraged and the
many monsters no longer appear on the
streets at night either it kind of makes
me view demons in the series in a
different way I mean even those who
don't want to hurt people cannot help
but cause problems simply by existing
and it also makes me wonder if guys like
vati or Ganondorf can still be redeemed
after all but that's another story
altogether with all that said let's
finish up the video by exploring one
final question is it possible that the
two phenomena batro and Feeney are
somehow connected while the two events
seem separate there are some
similarities to be found as well both
occur at night each involves a being who
has unfulfilled desires and both
entities have possibly existed on
skyloft since even before any of the
current day residents were alive there's
also the fact that batra lives right
below the graveyard and has even marked
one of the graves with a demonic symbol
could this be Feeney's grave perhaps and
it batra's influence lead to the
resurrection of her spirit intentionally
or unintentionally I mean maybe if
Phoenix return from the afterlife is
indeed due to batro's influence it could
even explain why she asks for paper in
Japanese culture there's a thing called
a no Fuda a sort of paper Talisman
sometimes used for purification or to
ward off an evil presence maybe Feeney
wanted to free herself from the Demonic
influence that's keeping her here of
course on the side of the developers the
whole paper thing is probably just a
recurring gag and nothing more hence why
I said that today's stories are most
definitely me overthinking it but like I
said it's part of creating a spooky
narrative another correlation between
Finney and batro I've been contemplating
is not that of a demonic Resurrection
but instead a personal connection I mean
think about it we have a girl who
clearly died at a young age and a
middle-aged looking man who could have
transformed into a demon at some point
of his life as opposed to being born as
one and as I explained earlier this can
happen due to powerful oftentimes
negative emotions which also Inc include
sadness and grief so what if Finney was
either related to him or at the very
least someone he was friends with And
the emotions over her loss led to him
becoming what he is today a sorrowful
demon longing for friendship and
restoring his Humanity
and that concludes this year's Halloween
episode a quick shout out to big deal
Blake for becoming a patreon and to all
of you for your continuous support
viewership and generosity you are all
amazing and I cannot thank you enough I
hope you have a great Halloween good
luck with them pumpkins and don't forget
to always check your candy for something
dangerous or gross I will see you all in
the next video this is Dawn signing off
and have a good one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]